un simple boîtier de quelques
centimètres carrés un capteur qui prend
place au coeur d'une ruche pour
comprendre la vie et les besoins des
cent cinquante mille abeilles de ce
rucher à l'initiative melli police une
toute jeune entreprise yvelinoise on va
relever surtout les gros maîtrise donc
là l'ami dit et on va dire ambiante
et puis la température à travers ses
dimensions va être capable de mesurer la
santé des seins et l'activité de l'eso
l'activité de l'essaim à certaines
périodes peut nous permettre de nous
alerter en cas d'anomalie puisque on a
on va dire les standards et en
comparaison assez ce temps là on sera
capable de dire ok ce n'est pas normal
aujourd'hui d'avoir ce taux d'humidité
meli police est en train d'équiper 18
ruche une installation possible grâce à
orange l'opérateur les a notamment mis
en relation avec la start up au stade vu
ça permet effectivement de faire entrer
une vieille profession dans dans l'ère
du 21e siècle avec la connexion 1 c'est
pas le tout comme dans les yvelines de
rendre plus de 400 mille logements
raccordables on en prend trois plus
qu'ils sont les logements déjà guèye
c'est un freak siens qui est humain qui
est financier effectivement comme dans
le cadre de cette action puisque c'est
nous qui prenons en charge par exemple
acquisition de des capteurs mais il est
également qu'un biologiste cris quand un
métier en thaïlande expertise pour tout
ce qui est un trait au numérique
le concept est aujourd'hui en études sur
deux communes chez nero concours et
shy'm et mélie police espère le
développer sur le courant de l'année
2020 en france près de 30% des colonies
disparaissent chaque année
les abeilles représente 35% de la
production alimentaire mondiale